yep little Greta Van Fleet for Friday
the power to destroy civilization Elon
musk's terrifying new warning on AI is
sure to get your attention the
billionaire Tech Tycoon telling Tucker
Carlson about his concerns watch this
AI is more dangerous than say mismanaged
uh aircraft design or production
maintenance or or bad car production in
the sense that it is
it has the potential however small one
make regard that probability but it is
non-trivial it has the potential of
civilizational Destruction
point just this week this is an
absolutely chilling story an Arizona mom
claimed that scammers used AI to clone
her daughter's voice so that they could
demand a one million dollar Ransom and
Joe Rogan issued a warning about AI
after someone created a fake complete
version of his podcast it wasn't him he
never had those guests on nothing about
it was real with AI technology
I am not the real Joe Rogan let me
repeat it once more I am not Joe Rogan
and the guests are not of the people
they portray this is purely fiction just
for fun so don't go around making little
clips for your tick tocks and make the
world believe I said things I never said
every single word of this podcast has
been generated with the help of chat GPT
it's just scary on so many levels and
you think about the potential criminal
level of this Janine and this mom her
daughter was on a ski trip she was with
her other daughter she gets a phone call
it's her daughter's voice saying crying
through sobbing tears mom I messed up I
messed up then a guy gets on the phone
and says I want a million dollars if you
want your daughter back and she says I
don't have the money then she gets it
down to 50 000. and everybody's trying
to help her they finally figured out
that her daughter was okay and was where
she thought she was this is happening a
lot actually well think about how it
happened before AI I mean when you got
an email or you got a text message or
you got a phone call wow that's the
point now it's going to be more real
than ever you know thousands scammed by
AI voices mimicking loved ones in
emergencies
um but but in addition to the criminal
aspects where they duplicate the voice
of a loved one I mean you've got the
other piece that that Elon Musk is
talking about and that is the basically
the potential of civilization
destruction what concerns me and what I
thought was fascinating and I don't know
if I'm Pro or Con on this I know I don't
know enough but they had a woman who
would never stop you before
thanks a lot but the woman who had lost
your seven-year-old daughter and she
used a i to try to duplicate her
daughter's voice and they had a picture
of the daughter and you could see with
these mechanical hands she was trying to
grab on to her daughter who would who's
deceased I can see people who lose a
loved one a husband loses a wife I gotta
hear them again I gotta see them again
this is going to change our lives what
about the guy with with the top secret
access to Chara 21 years old all right
how many people are going to do that and
use that as an opportunity to continue
to sell information you know that it
this is that we're not ready for this
we're absolutely not ready for it but I
I worry about the size psychological
capacity that people have to deal with
this whether it's fear whether it's
emotional trauma we're already on the
edge half of us are crazy not this half
that half clearly yes but it's I mean
when you think about Harold what Elon
Musk has been able to do in his life
right Rockets electric vehicles he's
trying to he's an AI take over Twitter
and now he's starting a new AI business
he's worked at it and researched in it
for a long time do you think that he has
the potential to to I mean everyone is
looking for someone to save the world
from the dangers of this you know is can
he do that can anybody do that at this
point well I think he is the Steve I'm
52. he's he's a I think a little older
than I am he he is the Steve Jobs of Our
Generation we have praised him around
this table for many things and we've
been mildly critical at times and we
thought that he deserved criticism his
voice to me is the leading voice around
technology and for him to say what he
said there in the clip we showed an
interview with Tucker which I look
forward to watching uh should should
disturb us all and make us all have some
pause I have a very clear position on
this and I disagreed with your person
who occupies that seat most nights Dana
and saying I think we should pause uh we
don't know enough about this we can
we're our concerns about China
surpassing us look China has to be
concerned about the same things we're
concerned about with this with this
technology can can an autocracy be
upended uh if a number of hundreds of
millions of people in the country decide
to use AI or organize around some AI
tool to do that so they have concerns as
well so I think we pause to understand
what Elon Musk is suggesting and even
not only him there are a number of
technologists and others who've
suggested that there's a problem the
judge and I talked about this on one of
the first days we we this issue came up
and we talked about who do you sue if
you're defamed we thought we heard our
own colleague Jonathan Turley that a
horrible thing happened to him who do
you sue who do you try to seek Justice
from when something like that happens so
the pause I think is necessary for a
variety of reasons
physio typical lawyer well who do you
hold accountable right I'm gonna hold
you accountable that's what Jesus Jesse
the Biden Administration says that they
want to have regulations around AI but
you know you get the very unnerving
feeling that they and most of most of
everybody doesn't really understand this
I think Elon Musk has probably a much
better handle on it than they do but
they want to start putting regulations
on it
does that concern you well Biden wants
to regulate it because if anyone's going
to be replaced with AI it's Joe Biden
I'm going to take an artificial stance
on artificial intelligence by the time
this thing gets going I'm going to be
dead so I don't care I don't understand
it's gonna take that long so I don't
care I don't pretend to understand it
like some people so I don't care a robot
can't replace me I'm not going to
interview a robot a robot would never
assassinate me it's inefficient
the problem is this Elon Musk is
building
robot cars so he has all these worries
because his robot cars are all crashing
his robot cars run by AI are driving
into lakes and they're blowing up or
they're driving into the middle of a
railroad track so that's what he's
worried about you need the human touch
behind the wheel of a self-driving AI
car but for instance let's say I'm
driving down the highway and I look to
my right and what do I see I see a
couple fornicating in the next store's
car now do I slow down I'd probably
speed up does a robot car see the other
car couple fornicating no they stay
right in their Lane they don't notice
the fornicating and then that
fornicating couple's car crashes into
them that's why you need someone behind
the wheel Sully is a great example Sully
saved lives he took the wheel of that
jet and made it come down a robot
couldn't have done that everyone gets
worried when there's new technology
that's introduced it happened with the
printing press it happened with nukes it
happened with the synthesizer all the
pianists were in a pickle oh I mean
they're gonna I steal my job these
synthesizers planning a piano is still
around there the point is this you're
not going to replace workers with these
robots because you can't cannibalize
your economy you need consumers also
notice when Americans got fat and
depressed 1978 if you look at the BMI
charts boom we all blow up into big
blimps that's because we stopped doing
heavy work and all sat behind desk in
front of computers now we're all fat and
stupid and depressed because we have the
machines doing everything do you want to
be the president of the United States
that lets 50 million robots replace 50
million human jobs no so it's not good
for them either
I think about Y2K and they told us that
was going to you know end the entire
Globe at that point and cloning was
going to you know suddenly everybody was
going to be cloned it was a panic so I
don't know whether This falls in that
category or not Greg yeah well uh after
that artificial stance I think my brain
is fried I think you've absolutely
completely I did the impossible I tried
gutfeld's bread so they're two they're
two kinds of AI right there's the uh
there's the information catcher right
and then there is the thing maker so
look I wanted to separate them because
there's two challenges in this the
information catcher is let's say you
have a mole on your on your shoulder and
you take a picture of it you put it into
your doctor you put it into your AI
doctor the doctor has control over all
the information in the universe every
medical study going back hundreds and
hundreds of years has every study
everything and comes back and tells you
it's this kind of thing and it's
99.999999 but it's way better than any
doctor tells you what what surgery what
you need to do the problem is who put
inputs inputs that info and does it have
a bias the problem is all human beings
have biases therefore AI will have a
bias too so so the ultimate kind of
decision making in this area for human
beings will be choosing choosing an AI
whose bias you favor
going to be just like cable news you're
going to have
a Fox News AI that you trust because
it's transparently biased they know our
opinions you're going to trust it but
you can't have a CNN AI because they
they lie they never tell you what they
believe so what's going to happen is oh
ultimately a biased AI will create it'll
be a world of different kinds of AI so
then you get to the the uh the AI that
makes things and you run into these the
uh the problem what if what do you do
when you create a machine that thinks
without a conscious without being
conscious right it's like it's like a
meter maid writing a ticket you can't
get her to stop that's the problem when
when AI artificial intelligence reaches
super intelligence where it's so
recursive it's faster thinking and
faster thinking and if it has a goal of
making a ham and cheese sandwich
and you're in the way of it making a ham
and cheese sandwich it has no moral
problem with getting rid of you it says
one goal so artificial intelligence the
danger here is super intelligence will
have a goal that will put before any
kind of moral reasoning
yes yes those are the things so the
pause is really about the making of
things because you don't want this
machine to get out of hand but the other
thing on us is we have to understand we
have to look at AI just like we look at
news that there's bias and they're human
bias I've tried to stop people from
writing tickets they always say the same
thing I can't stop that's non-conscious
thinking it's incredible you use
fornication synthesizer and pianists all
in this name so yeah apparently that
happens all the time on the highway
where Jesse drives Jersey now all right
coming up next
coming up next your kids don't belong to
you apparently according to some
liberals who claim that parent parental
rights can be a threat to our democracy
hi winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now